here with reaction the author of Trump
up Harvard Law School professor Alan
Dershowitz who many in the media said
I'd never invite back on the show which
is totally untrue and Fox News legal
analyst Gregg Jarrett welcome back up
both of you
Greg I know you've been poring through
all of these memos right what is
remarkable I think is what ed Henry
picked up on
I'm not sneaky and I don't leak okay
well he leaks we know he's sneaky and he
leaks and and so that puts a lie to that
statement the two things that jump out
at me is that the president expresses
that he's got this Russia cloud hanging
over him can you look into it and clear
it up and lift the cloud because Comey
had told the president you know he
didn't find any wrongdoing on his part
and when the president says please lift
the cloud Comey says we're running it
down the other thing that strikes me is
there is absolutely no evidence here of
any obstruction of justice you know this
is recounted conversation exactly as his
testimony there's nothing else in there
no red flags no smoking gun that would
incriminate the president and so as trey
gowdy who had seen this several months
ago said it's the best exhibit a defense
of President Trump you know let me go to
professor Dershowitz and professor
you're always welcome on the show
whether we agree or disagree i deep
respect for you and i know we disagree
on on the hill a lot of the Hillary part
of this which I'll be glad to get into
bullets let's first go to the leak that
that's a crime if we're gonna be
technical 18 USC 793 greg jarrett you've
taught me a lot in the last year number
one when you couple this nothing about
russia collusion rod Rosenstein
statement to the president that he's not
under he's not a target in either case
the new york case or Muller's case does
that does that not put emphasis on the
fact that there was no collusion
whatsoever
well collusion is not a crime I've seen
no evidence of collusion an obstruction
of justice can't be charged against a
sitting president for
exercising his authority under Article 2
of the Constitution but if I were the
president I would be concerned about the
Southern District of New York which is
probably why he brought Rudy Giuliani
onto his team who was the former US
Attorney in the Southern District of New
York because as I've told clients for 53
years you can't have any confidence that
your best friend your brother your
sister-in-law won't flip if the
government charges them with serious
crimes
you can charge people with a series of
technical crimes that could result in
life imprisonment the pressure is
intense and then the pressure is not
only to sing but to compose because what
happens is a witness knows that he'll
get a better deal if he can elaborate if
he can make up stories have he can tell
the government what the government wants
to hear and that may not always be the
truth so I don't think that President
Trump is out of the woods yet I think he
has to be concerned about the Southern
District of New York I don't think he
ever had any real vulnerability from the
special counsels investigation of the
Russia thing but I'll tell you all the
stuff that's coming out now confirms
what I've said from day one there should
have been a nonpartisan national
commission of experts looking into the
entire 2016 election faults on all sides
what was the Russian effort what did
they do
what did each of the candidates do
without criminais ssin just to avoid a
repetition of this in the future when
you start side looking for crimes you
don't end up getting the truth Devon
Nunez warned everybody it was public
into in an op-ed in The Washington Times
that Russia was going to do this number
one and if you remember just a couple of
weeks before the election it was
President Obama saying no serious person
would ever believe that any foreign
entity can ever have any impact on our
election elections and lectured Donald
Trump to stop whining the wealth is
adorable tried to have an impact on the
election of Benjamin Netanyahu I have
absolutely no doubt that he is a
minister says that try to get
not on yahoo unelected and you know the
United States has tried to influence
foreign elections going back years and
years to Central America and South
America so of course we should be
concerned with the Russians trying to
influence our elections there's you know
what we did is nothing compared to what
the Russians tried to do now whether
they succeeded or had an impact I don't
know but I do think that this is a
national problem that all Americans
should be concerned with on a
nonpartisan basis this is something that
the Russians always partisan comment
I'll throw this to Greg that's why you
can't take classified top-secret special
access programming in from information
and to avoid congressional oversight put
it on a mom and pop shop server that
Cole even wrote in his original
exoneration of Hillary Clinton that we
believe properly Russia foreign foreign
intelligence disease got ahold of let me
ask you about this criminal referral
today about Andrew McCabe and the fact
that Kobe could be a witness against his
own number two yeah I mean you've got
Comey who says McCabe's the liar McCabe
says come he's a liar well somebody's a
liar and maybe actually both of them
aren't or none of them or not no I must
say that today the Inspector General
said that the the lies were quote
knowing and intentionally made and they
have evidence of that that's very
powerful language and so I would expect
that McCabe would be charged maybe as
many as four different charges for four
different lives and Comey may soon be
sitting nearby in another courtroom
facing his own charges I count at least
six potential criminal statutes that
Comey may have violated and and so you
agree with with congressman to Sanford
says letter did you agree with him on
the law Greg yeah absolutely he nailed
the law in exactly the same fashion that
you and I have talked about for months
and we had put up on the screen all the
different statutes DeSantis and the
other members of Congress cited the same
statues but a professor because we're
almost out of time and and this maybe is
an area where we we do disagree and I
urge you I know that if I had subpoenaed
my server and my emails and I deleted
after after subpoenaed 33000 acid wash
cleaned the harddrive with bleach pit
and bust up devices with hammer that to
me shows full intent which would fulfill
the mandate that even Comey acknowledges
as it relates to obstruction but more
importantly I think you will agree with
me professor that as a civil libertarian
that when Hillary Clinton pays for a
dossier through a literally a foreign
agent that they hired through Perkins
Cooley and funneled the money fusing GPS
the FBI at the DOJ nobody verified the
information corroborated it it's
presented to a FISA Court they don't
tell the FISA Court judge that an
opposition party candidate gave it to
them that is a net we we lose our
country in my view professor if that
happens again it's that dangerous look I
agree I think failing to give the FISA
Court all the negative information so it
could evaluate the credibility and lack
of credibility of that request for a
warrant was a serious serious flaw my
problem was when you list all these
statutes you make my point and that is
under a federal criminal law almost
anybody can be charged with anything if
you look hard enough on the area of
perjury remember scoota living i believe
he told the truth somebody else told a
different truth and so they prosecuted
him for perjury i think that happens
more often than anybody thinks and you
have to be very worried about expanding
the criminal law and targeting people
based on this accordion-like criminal
law that every civil libertarian should
be concerned about
well said professor and by the way
you're always welcome even if you want
to yell it not a great point well we're
doing it when I think you deserve no I'm
very well aware it was all over the
place thank you sir I appreciate your
insight and Greg thank you